we mentioned that this week is the
beginning of celebrations for the Lunar
New Year all around the world the most
festive time of the year in China in
particular especially this year after
nearly all covered restrictions were
removed for the first time since 2020.
as Elizabeth Palmer reports this is
happening after a long delayed and huge
spike in coveted cases there
in his New Year video address president
Xi Jinping admitted that China's coveted
surge had been Fierce and fast
that's no understatement a top Chinese
epidemiologist estimates 80 percent of
China's population has now been infected
that's more than a billion people most
since the start of December Chinese
Health officials have confirmed just
under 80 000 coveted deaths but Western
analysts think that's a wild
understatement we expect that the number
of deaths will peak in around one week
ahead and it will reach the 1 million
Mark so 1 million of total deaths at the
end of this month we may never know the
real toll especially as Chinese doctors
are under pressure not to list covid on
death certificates over the past week
millions of Chinese City dwellers
traveled home to Villages and towns for
the Lunar New Year
there were concerns they might take the
virus with them setting off a second
lethal wave the CBS team headed to the
provincial city of Zhao Tong shooting
covertly as covet is a sensitive subject
they found the virus had arrived some
time ago one woman explained her mother
had tested positive and a man waiting
said uh almost everyone around here has
tested positive like 80 percent
it does appear that China's covet
outbreak has peaked and is starting to
decline if that's true and the economy
starts picking up the new year is indeed
off to an auspicious start
for CBS mornings Elizabeth Palmer Tokyo